I think we often see leadership
development as self development there's
the individual level that's where we're
really thinking about you as a person
you know a good leader understands what
she has to do to make herself develop
but there's a second level that's the
organizational level a great leader
understands and does what she has to do
to help others to develop most leaders
are not running entire companies most
leaders are touching only a handful of
people maybe they don't have any formal
leadership authority but they do touch
their peers and their colleagues at work
and those interactions are opportunities
to show leadership all of us are
challenged to engage in behaviors that
essentially have leadership implications
for the people around us how do your
actions as a leader affect the growth
mindset of others and then finally the
third level of analysis is the
environment of the organization this
includes society economy the broader
culture the natural environment the
things each of us do at work not only
matter for work they also matter for the
broader world because our actions as
leaders in order for us to be
exceptional also will have implications
at that third level transform your
approach to leadership excellence and
development learn more about SCP the
Stanford executive program
[Music]